Viva hysteria the film opens with a
montage of what is images from your
career the highlights how did it feel
when you first sat down and saw all of
that well we cut all those bits of
footage we've seen them before but never
in six minutes and it's squashed
together segments when we first approved
it you know obviously a lot of emotions
go through your mind when you think
about Dom Valley or you think about
Steve you know on all the early days and
right up to Vivian join in and beyond
you know that once we'd seen it and you
let it go and he's just something that
we stood behind for 11 shows you used
certain parts of it is triggers to write
you say you and me you know SAP cite
something on me saying quick now the
last time you get a blow your nose or
you know check your knock on tire I'll
stop you sure before you go out there
and there says you know the show starts
but it's yeah it's I mean you take any
band they swing together for 35 years
and put a montage just six minutes of
their career together it's gonna throw
up a lot of weird stuff the film was
filmed live in Las Vegas and talked to
me about the venue because a lot of
people thought was sort of an unusual
choice for you guys and smaller than
what you normally yeah it was a nice a
intimate but it was like it was about
two thousand Sita well you get the idea
he wasn't it wasn't a stadium and he
certainly wasn't like one of these big
event gigs that America or a good at
home hosting it the great thing about it
was the actual stage and the production
was a big show production but it was
actually it was managed to fit in in
almost like a theater setting you know
and and and that was that was one of the
great things about doing it you know
it's the Hard Rock Cafe in in Vegas we
we asleep laid various every term pretty
much every time we'd tour America but to
actually be there for the better part of
three weeks actually on the same stage
every night was I that really appealed
you know it was like no traveling you
know it's just
just had a ring to it and is something
we've never done before and we always
love doing things we've never done
before because you know that's it just
keeps things fresh and how do you feel
your music and you as a band have
changed and develops over the years
because your musics been described in
many different ways by lots of different
people but for you guys personally how's
it evolved so hard well yeah we all
write differently you know everybody
everybody right if we're on left to our
own devices we write songs you have a
certain style that will fit the DEF
LEPPARD mold or not you know and if they
know sometimes if you're right saying
well there's no way electric ademma do
this so you you pass it on to somebody
else are you doing another band or
something like that or you write songs
specifically tailored to fit because we
are good songwriters and we can he
suddenly said to us
Oh committing you to write a song that
sounds like Chas & Dave you know we
could do it if we wanted to
somebody said right so I'll write Led
Zeppelin we could do that as well
but when you're right from your heart
you just write and luckily most of the
time when we write as individuals we do
brings onto the table everybody throws
their little bit in and adds to the pop
and it comes out as a Def Leppard song
or occasionally what we'll do is we come
to the table with bits of songs and we
glue it together a bit of Samson if it
fills a bit of Vivian's and then we
start warming lalala and melodies over
and then writing lyrics and it's a total
ban effort he changes all the time you
know I mean we always used to write as a
team then we started writing as
individuals and then we go back to
writing as a team again it just really
and you guys talked about without
spoiling anything as a moment at the
start of the film and it's mentioned
that you know you kind of walk down one
specific concert and there was a lot of
people there and it went through your
minds that you know you were playing in
pubs 10 years ago do you ever get used
to playing big venues is it always
special yeah we absolutely get used to
it in fact they did that's where we
always saw ourselves you know that'll be
the phone for you job well then get on
yet seriously from day one we we had a
vision of ourselves plane huge gigs we
we just I mean you know rightly or
wrongly it was probably a bit naive at
the time but that's where we saw
ourselves and you know to us that's
where
music kind of belongs we wrote songs for
that environment and out of all the
geeks you've played are there any that
specifically stand out you know it's
been good or bad or anything like
specific memories for you that you think
aren't you know what they you know Vegas
is hard to beat really because you know
he's fresh in the mind but it was 11
shows in the same venue and as such says
you know that the lack of trouble is
gives you so much more energy to put on
a show and you just take in service
elevators from the backstage area
Mukilteo room looks like that doesn't
get any better it's almost like living
at home and doing the gig you know but
there's been a lot of great gigs Don you
know Don Valley in in 93 first ever gig
in a brand new stadium in our hometown
that was good Jack Murphy Stadium back
in 83 when we first broke in America and
we ended up we finished the American
tour it's one of 55,000 people we
started that tour six months early in
the Marquee in london in front of 600
you know I mean it was as a yardstick it
was like incredible how quickly the band
became popular those things you know you
never forget them I'm trying to think of
a really you know like a bad gig because
that'd be more interesting struggling we
must have done some bad yeah memorably
bad obviously we've all had gigs where
one of us has been bad through either
illness or you know injury or something
either but not through lack of trying
you know we've never been that kind of
man they just say I'll call me mother
you know I mean if I've got laryngitis
and I you go on stage you're never gonna
sound right you know if South slices his
finger and off trying to peel an orange
he's gonna struggle the play but you
know that's the great thing about a band
when one part I heard is injured the
rest kind of you know circle the wagons
and protect you know and carry through
as a team well what strikes me is you
guys is you genuinely seem to have such
a strong bond and a friendship has it
always been like that is that always the
case or have you had a couple of
thoughts
oh there's God yeah there's oh it does
Oh
in arguments and fights along along the
way after 13 years it would be pretty
unusual and actually unnatural if it
wasn't but from from the outset yeah I
mean pretty much and it's it's not
rocket science you know with would
reasonably all of us a reasonably
easygoing we got respect for each other
we but we all kind of like what we do
you know ninety percent at the time
which is which is pretty good and yeah
it's it's something you only really
analyzing interviews or something like
that it's just you know it's the most
natural thing I've never been in another
band this is the butler the only band
I've ever been it you know Vivian and
Phil they that was obviously been in
bands previous but this is all I know so
to me is completely normal and I can't
understand why other bands oh I think
it's as a band you've been together 35
years very long time and you've been
through some really tough times as a
band you know you really sadly lost a
member and you had your drummer Rick is
amazing because he he had a car accident
and lost his arm but he continues you
know how do you keep going when in times
like that you do that through music
stubborn I don't know yeah you know what
when Rick lost his arm we can have made
a point I mean I you know let's be
honest we probably all thought well
that's the end of his career then for
three minutes or something but then when
he became count obviously it's like well
you know what if he thinks he can carry
on doing this it's his choice if he
wants to remain in the band we're not
gonna fire you know fire family members
if they have an accident then we were
pretty much family you know even way
back then but we'd all be together six
or seven years by name it's it's just
one of those things where were either
stubborn or we just believe that we've
got more to say and it's not time to
quit yet you know I mean when when it is
time to go I think we'll know but right
now we're having such a good time doing
it and when you think about it I mean
we've been around for 35 years but
considering or who's still around doing
it beyond what we've done
you know with stones and celebrate in 50
years Aerosmith Harris McCartney's I
mean this sting I mean there's all these
people being around a lot longer those
so as long as you kind of you think
you've got an audience ur gonna enjoy
doing what you do and you were enjoying
doing it yourself there's no real reason
why you shouldn't want to stop it said
it's not just a ten year thing anymore
like it was in the seventies so
consequently you know it's like why
would I want to retire you no longer
know go fishing yeah I mean you know we
don't necessarily do 300 shows a year
anymore
but you don't have to I'd rather do it
well and then often if you like and if
we can do specialist things like what
we're doing now you know 11 shows in Las
Vegas has turned into an enormous ly
successful project if you like for us
and it's becoming obviously there's a
lot of intrigue and a lot of people
asking about it so it was a genuinely
good decision to make to do that rather
than just going on a regular old tour
you know so it stands out from the crowd
a bit more that's where we're kind of
interested in going and we worked five
years ago with Taylor Swift and people
look to his own we had three heads I
said well why wouldn't way you know
because it's she's a huge fan and he was
a chance for us to do something a little
different and and so was very good yeah
that was a very unusual collaboration
with Taylor Swift like you said it
shocked a lot of people and how was it
working with her cuz you know she's kind
of this country girl sweetheart and then
back but when you when you if anybody
dead or just had the time to really
analyze it her songs although they come
from a country back background they're
not really strictly country songs the
the content with their pop the pop songs
with a with a country feel and from
where we come from although you know
from the very onset people called as
heavy metal with what we did which was
right pop songs that came out of the
heavy metals your honor if you like so
there was a similarity there already is
is bringing
the songs into a more mainstream place
and we obviously part of that
particularly shell was plain each of
those songs and you know they they sort
of flowed into each other without review
without you really knowing whose homes
if you didn't you know if you weren't
aware the artists so it you know it does
work and you know that's just one of the
great things about you know doing what
you do you can do things like that
well upcoming projects have you got that
we can look forward to we did a bit of a
holding part at the moment we can
discuss fill our guitar player stage
left as just had surgery on his left
hand so he's gonna be in a pot for about
six or seven weeks so he can't play
Vivian's recovering from cancer and he's
got his eighth and final chemo treatment
later this week so we've got a you know
everybody heal and like the film do the
work for this floor and that gives
everybody a chance to be at home do the
thing we've never had the chance to do
in 35 years which is enjoy the family or
their house or the garden whatever you
know not having them get up and jump on
a plane or a bus every day and and
that's where the your artistic muse
kicks in because I can guarantee between
now and the end of the year me and him
without even knowing it will end up get
you know picking a guitar up and going
and then phone into there going you want
to get together I've got this song you
know and I can guarantee there be I mean
that's the one thing that comes out of
periods like this these new material any
tenants and it comes out naturally it's
not because we've got three weeks to
write a song and you know you can do
under the spotlight it will it will
evolve like that and come Christmas then
we I know that we will have some good
material that came out of this
particular period
you